welcome welcome in to Market takes I'm
your host Dion rabone reporter for the
Wall Street journalist and I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me and I appreciate
it there is a lot going on this week A
lot happened this week but I'm going to
tell you the three most important things
you need to be looking out for this week
as we move forward uh through the
economic calendar listen if you were
paying attention last week you saw a big
sell-off in stocks you say big sell-off
in bonds this week a lot could happen we
expect a lot of market movement because
of just what's going on in the economic
calendar I'm going to tell you all about
that the biggest thing you need to watch
out for number one that is the Central
Bank the Jackson Hole meeting of the fed
or the FED Symposium in Jackson Hole
Wyoming that's coming up this week it
starts on Thursday August 24th the FED
chairman Jerome Powell will be speaking
on Friday and everyone and I do mean
everyone who's anyone in economics in
the markets will be tuned in and
listening to hear what the chairman has
to say we also get new and existing home
sales reports this week really those
have been a lot more highly watched
because of the impact that housing and
really uh all the the things that people
are paying for in terms of rent housing
prices uh mortgage costs all those
things have been very watched because
the impact they've had on inflation and
finally we get surveys on the U.S
services and Manufacturing sectors they
could tell us a lot about what's coming
up next for the stock market so listen
let's dive into it let's start with
talking about Jackson Hole that starts
this week on Thursday of course like I
said we get the FED speech or the FED
chairman speech on Friday it's the fed's
annual Gathering of central Bankers from
around the world and usually the Fed
chair in his speech in his or her speech
right in previous times but this year in
the FED chairman speech he's going to be
laying out his vision for where we've
been and also where we're going and
that's going to tell us a lot because a
lot of the changes that we've seen in
markets have been dictated by
expectations for what the fed's going to
do next how high they'll raise policy
how long they'll hold policy High and
that's really what's driving a lot of
really just about all of what you see in
the markets especially stock and bond
markets right now and we're going to
hear from the FED chairman on Thursday
on Friday excuse me but we're also going
to hear from lots of other Central
Bankers from around the globe like I
said when they when they gather together
at this meeting usually there is an a
sort of Central Bank con you know they
all come together and they say hey
here's what we think is going on there's
a lot of agreement right now there's a
lot of uncertainty a lot of not being
really sure of what comes next or where
we are how we got here especially when
we look around the globe right now we've
got inflation really staying high in
Europe not coming down the same way that
it has in the U.S and Latin America
where central banks have really been
able to pull that inflation down from
about eight nine percent here in the U.S
down to about three three and a half
percent where inflation currently is
over in Europe and especially in England
the bank of England and the European
Central Bank are dealing with higher
rates of inflation then really we are
over here and so the questions are
because central banks know that
inflation isn't just a standard about oh
what happens here happens here those
things travel inflation travels and
inflation and investors and central
banks know this and they know that
inflation moves globally so we're going
to talk about all those things also you
got to talk about Japan the bank of
Japan has not only not raised rates the
way the rest of the world has they're
still buying they're still buying
government bonds and keeping those
interest rates down so how do all those
things relate to one another we're going
to hear about that and we're going to
hear from the FED chairman since there
is no fed meeting this month not till
September 20th 21st that's when we get
the next fed meeting but this Symposium
this week will be just as highly watched
and in fact probably more so because the
the FED chairman is going to analyze the
economy where it's been and where it's
going really another thing they're going
to talk about hopefully is financial
conditions and how those are affecting
small businesses we've seen really the
stock market ratchet up higher over the
past really for most of this year and
then this week it's really just our last
week sorry last week the market just
kind of Tanked off but we will see how
things are going or how they think
things are going for small businesses
it's been a tough time it's hard to get
money for loans hard to borrow hard to
sell a lot of things hard to find
employees all those things small Banks
or small businesses excuse me are
dealing with because of a lot of what's
happening in the banking sector one
thing I want to put up here on your
screen the first chart I want to do is I
want to throw to what's going on in the
bond market so I'm going to put a chart
up here on your screen right now just to
show you what we're looking at and
what's on your screen right there is the
10-year yield that's the most traded the
most well known of all the treasuries
now you see that Spike there at the edge
we are up the highest level since 2007.
now those bond yields are over 4.25
we've come down a little bit on the
yields but we are still well above 4.25
over 4.3 as you see there on your screen
that's the highest that yields have been
since 2007. that is really all about fed
policy and when you see that Spike there
that we saw last week that really is
just one week you see that Spike higher
and that's a big deal and that just
illustrates the way that fed
expectations and expectations for policy
can move the market this has really been
all about that higher than expected CPI
reporter not higher than expected but
higher than recent CPI report and GDP
which was higher than expected now the
Atlanta feds GDP now uh tracker is
predicting we will get 5.8 percent uh
GDP growth in the third quarter that
would be a huge blowout quarter to put
that in comparison last uh in the second
quarter we got 2.4 percent GDP growth
quarter before that two percent so this
would be more than double what we've
seen and just showing a real
acceleration in U.S GDP growth that's
something that generally is good you
want more growth you want the economy
getting bigger but at a wrap at a very
rapid Pace would be at the face we're
going and that could mean inflation
starts to re-accelerate and the FED has
to do more so definitely going to want
to keep your eye on what the FED has to
say at Jackson Hole at its meeting uh
this week next up existing home sales
and new home sales those are gonna be
out on Tuesday and Wednesday first thing
we want to talk about is the existing
home sales report because that's the big
one it also comes out first so we get to
talk about it first so let's throw up
here on your screen a chart of existing
home sales and what we have seen from
that going back to the beginning of
2022. you see up there it's up high more
than 6 million homes sold per month and
that's coming down all the way to begin
in 2023 and then you see it pick back up
again and we've been kind of coming down
so the big question is do the July
numbers continue that decline that
deceleration of home sales or do they
pick back up now this is very important
because mortgage rates have hit their
highest in 22 years just last week
mortgage rate is the highest in 22 years
the highest average rate at least for
the Third 30-year mortgage in 22 years
and if those numbers do pick back up if
you do see an increase in the number of
sales well that tells you that people
are just shrugging those off and and
moving on with their lives and still
continuing to go out and take those
mortgages on buy those homes and that's
a big deal because again it means
they're paying a higher price and if
they're buying a home and planning to
rent it out they're going to charge
higher rent so this chart really just
illustrating the movement that we have
seen from the existing home sales report
and how that could be impacting and how
it could impact inflation expected to
decline this next month by 0.2 percent
month over month uh keep showing that
level period That's What economists are
expecting we'll see if that happens last
month sales declined by 3.3 percent
prices fell by 0.9 percent but year over
year you saw prices start to pick or
month over month excuse me you saw
prices start to pick back up so as those
prices rise as those rates rise you
could see you know again inflation start
to rise but a lot of people have already
been priced out of them of the housing
market even more people could continue
to be pressed out of the housing market
because we know about 80 percent of
sales come from that existing home sales
market and again as inflation has cooled
housing has accounted for 60 to 80
percent of overall core inflation of the
core CPI that we've seen so this is a
big deal for inflation a big deal for
the FED a big deal for the overall
market so it'll be highly watched let's
talk about next that new home sales
report I want to put that chart up here
on your screen as well so you can take a
look at what we've been seeing this
chart going back to 2020. I wanted to
put this on your screen to just give you
a little bit more context about what
we're seeing now in at the end of 2020
you see those numbers really start to
pick up there and going into 2021 over a
million sales per month that's big for
new home sales those are usually much
lower we are not getting back towards
that just yet we're still if you look
out there on 2023 we're closer to that
800 000 but we are picking up we're
seeing continued increase in new home
sales and largely that's because there's
been a lot more new home supply a lot of
those Home Builders stocks have been
going through the roof because they're
building building and they're finding
all kinds of folks that want to buy
those new homes because they're saying
you know what if I got to Shell out a
ton of money I might as well get a new
house so this chart again just
illustrates the pickup that we've seen
and the increase that we've seen
consistently in new home sales as there
has not been supply of existing home
sales no one wants to sell their house
and move but there is been an increase
in new homes and that has made new homes
a bigger part of the overall housing
market than what we've seen last but not
least want to talk about the
manufacturing and services PMI reports
that we will get this month that we will
get sorry this week about last month
those are going to tell us just how
folks are feeling about the economy on
the services side is in your Barber your
auto mechanic your lawyer those folks
and then on the manufacturing side those
big businesses and this could be big for
stocks because right now we're seeing
manufacturing really in a lull it's been
low folks of saying they're having low
confidence things aren't going well but
it's picked up recently we need to see
if that continues is there continued
kind of bullishness enthusiasm for the
manufacturing sector or are people still
having negative feelings about it and
showing that's going down if those
continue to move lower it could suggest
more trouble for the stock market
because again if you've got first of all
let's point out most public companies
and manufacturers rather than services
companies when you think about the
companies that are public that make up
the S P 500 and especially the Dow it's
a lot more manufacturers a lot more
businesses that make things or at least
that produce things another week reading
could suggest okay well if rates have to
stay high because inflation's not coming
down but business sentiment is
deteriorating in business conditions are
deteriorating well that environment
could stick around for a long time and
that's not a good thing services on the
other hand have been strong but they
have started to weaken so you're kind of
seeing manufacturing been weak but
getting a little better service has been
strong but getting a little worse we'll
see what happens on those fronts this
week Hey listen that's going to do it
for us here on Market takes hope you
enjoyed your time with us I am Dion
rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal we hope you'll come back and do
it with us when we're right here again
next time